yeah it looks like russia has been
planning this almost it looks like
china's not really on board but they
were growing their gold and their
reserves so as an investor it looks like
this is affecting u.s markets the u.s
markets have been pretty volatile in the
last week or so uh but our people
already have people already priced like
the rate hike in enough and like kind of
the uncertainty that's going on right
now uh globally like it affects because
cpi will go up um gas and energy will go
up but the overall like technology
company
how much will they really lose and like
as an investor should you be nervous
about that right now yeah great question
so this has less to do with sort of
company fundamentals and more to do with
the ecosystem that is the global
financial markets right and so you know
tightening liquidity
all else all things being equal will
reduce asset market valuations you know
in particular in risk assets and you
know things that you have to take credit
risk or duration risk any sort of risk
liquidity risk um to to to to take
advantage of and so you know something
like a russia ukraine you know in an
environment where growth is trending
lower
is something that can have a you know
real deleterious and potentially
meaningful impact on that ecosystem
because the sort of foundational
principle of growth slowing is an issue
right if we were doing this in like the
summer of 2020 or even you know first
half of 2021
it would have been absorbed it would
have been a few headlines a few weeks of
headlines but then it would fade to the
background because we're all high-fiving
each other about how good corporate
profits are and how robust gdp growth is
and how good the labor market is the
problem is we're on the back side of
those sign curves and you know in terms
of how our brains are wired to think you
know danny kahneman amos diversity has
done a tremendous amount of work on this
um with respect to prospect theory but
our brains are effectively wired to to
think and rate of change terms and to
think it relative to to to the outcomes
as opposed to what the actual outcome is
and so
we're just in a bad point in the
broader growth inflation policy
valuation positioning cycles
for this not to be a problem and that
that's the that was a real issue john
that made a lot of sense and then what
do you think about jerome powell's
comments about two global reserve
currencies the possibility of them
coexisting oh i didn't see that but to
me that sounds more like heresy
and and it's not to say that i have a
view on that or disagree with it it's
just to say that again the us and this
is my foundational view for a really
long period of time which is the us has
the biggest guns
and the biggest military and the highest
sort of incentive structure associated
with maintaining the status quo
in terms of the global reserve currency
system so you can expect a nuclear war
before we
get rid of that that that status get
ready give that that that exorbitant
privilege up that's mark darius delve
said that yeah yeah are you concerned
about uh the nuclear side when it comes
to what's going on now do you think
that's made the main reason why the u.s
and other strong countries have stayed
out of kind of dropping troops off and
doing these things is because russia's
vast nuclear weapons
yes um
putin again putin is a psychopath he's a
thug and i think you know when thugs get
pushed
you know their image becomes the most
important
um aspect of what it is that they're
doing right it's not about sort of
thoughtful calculation of is this the
right choice is this gonna have
consequences or not it's more about
i have to portray this image as a tough
guy i have to portray whatever lack you
know legacy view or legacy um image that
i've already put out there and so to me
that heightens the chance that we do
have some sort of nuclear conflict now
is that probability more than 10
probably not you know again like i said
it's it's very unlikely that ukraine can
hold off russian forces russian forces
of you know that magnitude for an
extended period of time you know they're
having a trouble because they
miscalculated on how much resistance
they were going to initially get right
you know you got they got popped in the
mouth a little bit um it's like trying
to you know tackle the little guy and
it's like oh no look guys they're back
you know they're stealing your tanks and
stuff yeah
they were selling them on ebay
they're trying somebody said 400
ukraine or someone might have said like
if you sell it you don't have to pay
capital gains tax
[Laughter]
so they're incentivizing people to uh to
take and steal the tanks which is funny
yeah no they they should i mean but look
at the end of the day so
summarizing what i was trying to say
which is look
i think putin will use whatever force is
necessary
because his image is at stake now his
tough guy images steak has less to do
with what's happening in ukraine and how
much they need to take over ukraine i
think he's willing to do whatever's
necessary will he need to do whatever is
necessary most likely not they're gonna
you know it's probably a matter of days
or weeks before they ultimately succeed
in this in this mission but the problem
is what does success look like on the
back end
you know what is you are you going to
occupy ukraine indefinitely that's a
that's a tall order i mean we had a very
difficult time occupying iraq and you
know kind of keeping boots on the ground
in afghanistan with very little to no
success i mean hey actually sorry i
would say no success but you saw the
second we pulled out of afghanistan how
unsuccessful that after two weeks it was
already very bad
so and so the reality is it's it's this
is just a bad choice by putin in terms
of trying to take advantage of a real
weak in in um
a real you know pernicious time in the
global financial structure right like we
have already high inflation we already
got policy tightening coming ahead of
this
financial markets are volatile economic
growth is trending lower you know
there's you know talk of recession and
by the back end of the year beginning of
next year which by the way i think i was
on your program a couple months ago and
i think i was remember i said that yeah
two months ago i was like you know but
everyone's going to be talking about
recession by the end of this year and
now it's like that's because
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time